and we are welcome to the iron Lords
podcast episode number 31 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day we
have a lot of gaming to discuss so we're
gonna get right into it so of course
let's introduce those usual suspects at
the round table
my co-host with the Coe most my brother
from another mother and the how of the
young wolf my man Lord addict how are we
doing sir our cannon plane destiny
that's all I feel your face right now
grand Gadget and of course our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience kind of always offline
Illuminati is like always disappointed
with last night's uh combat sports but
uh
apart from that doing good glad to be
here and of course the excess gamer Oh
slash boxing aficionado the Lord who is
a better with convictions and demands
nothing less than a premium experience
be love a lord King how are we doing
sinner we're doing fantastic um I like
to say a shout out to everybody that got
in the combat sports yesterday you were
able to get it from various different
angles you had it from the UFC with
rocky lock old fight um first is David
branch which I thought was going in was
going to be a fantastic fight I really
didn't like how it ended I wanted a more
definitive ending to it um but I was
pleased with the action in the fight it
it lived up to the billing for me and
rocky is on his
- you know avenging that loss that he
took um you had the Billy Joe Saunders
vs. Monroe fight that was on you know
free television it was kind of boring
lackluster you know but let's get to the
main event the main event last night
fellas you had canola versus triple G
some people trying to say that this was
fight of the Year candidate coming in
this was supposed to be the fight of the
century
it was supposed to up seat uh Mayweather
vs. Pacquiao in the same sense it lived
up to me whether Pacquiao and I'm not
gonna spend too much time on this boxing
I gave boxing for the people that's out
there that want to hear this boxing talk
and once it hear UFC talk there you know
combat sports stories this is the
greatest year in combat history alright
I want you to understand from from point
A to point B you have written down
verses Romanenko at the end of the year
December 9th that will be fight of the
year but last night we must remove the
corruption out of box and move the drugs
out of UFC we if we Khmers the two
sports and get it to the ideal utopia it
will be fantastic we can't blame the
fighters the fighters just fight all
right everything else is outside of
their hands so when you watch a sport
don't don't don't be upset with what's
going on outside of the sport as long as
those two combatants come in and then
get it on enjoy it you know a drink be
merry eat be married be safe enjoy it
don't get into fights and debates over
the outcomes because these fighters do
not have control over this stuff it's
that it was very disheartening but I'm
glad that triple G didn't lose his belts
over BS you know he didn't get the loss
you got a draw and you know going in you
weren't the main attraction you weren't
the money man you weren't the promoters
choice you were first time fighting in
Vegas so the casinos had a vested
interest in Canelo winning because
Canelo would be back to bring back money
to Vegas if you this your first time
fighting the Vegas Vegas don't know you
bro all right so let's get on when I
came and talked no I don't like to say
about comments where this was now the
big word so president Lord slash boxy
aficionado giving us updates that we
like it you gotta follow for that King
you take or these these these things cow
bats works that's good and of course it
is like a you know here spreading that
gaming realness
on the ILP not telling you what you want
to hear but what you need to hear so we
got no guest this week but it's just the
laws like it always has been from day
one so we want to get into what the
Lord's are playing so let's start with
my man Lord addict I know you've been
going hard on that destiny so what
anything else going on to which was
specifically in destiny
what about what specifically you rocking
them raised what you doing helping
people get through the raids myself I
should have been a but I hoped a bunch
of people get through the majority of it
so I didn't because um I was on a tick
podcast a tick Network last night I was
special guest star filling in for the
for the great legendary Lord be money
and um yeah man they shouted you out man
it was like really knows how to help
people who you know never run a raid and
and do stuff I want to shout out more
sinister than all the people I know Lord
King with the bad Eugene crew you know
saying like is really cool to have
someone that actually knows what they're
doing and to tell people who knew how to
get in this spot so to speak
it's really cool what you're doing
because a lot of people give you a lot
of credit when I even give you credit
because I always tell you like you know
sighs Mona King or sinister and yourself
you know like yo you're one of your good
really good teacher explaining mechanics
in a rage so that was good to see them
[Laughter]
many talents so let's get to Lord saw up
what have you been playing this week
believe it or not I mean I've been
working a lot so I haven't been able to
give put in a lot of time but when I
have has been destiny me know you guys
really I know I'm not on for I haven't
been on I can't say like an hour at a
time so it's like I don't want to hook
up with you guys and then have to leave
because that's always what I have to do
so but I've been slowly grinding away
I'm at 263 power so I'm getting up there
I'm getting up there but when I have a
like a bulk of the time like 3-4 hours
I'm gonna get on which I need your help
with strikes now I wanna start start
getting into this raid stuff but that's
pretty much what I've been playing and
more Mario rabbits on switch when I'm
done now my question for you lost saw it
as far as the UM the Destiny stuff like
what specifically you've been doing just
like if you finished the story yet or
here we have with that no I have not
finished the story so you can tell you
can tell my blade I'm at 263 with not
without finishing the story
blazing oh yeah even blazing other
things aside to content yeah okay yeah I
haven't done crucible yet that's just
not really my thing but I will at some
point um a lot of just like the public
events whenever they come up doing the
adventures I mean story wise I'm up to
IO so I don't know how much more there
is beyond that but I'm there but yeah
the public events man like I honest
I've gotten obsessed with the grind of
like watching and watching the numbers
go up man what numbers go up I have a
bunch of exotics now and stuff like that
so I have to say this I get it I get it
I get why you got nothing but destiny
like Lord addict says running people
through age not progressing past because
somebody pulled me and it was like you I
need your help
get in here please dude that I haven't
seen for I think a year and a half from
destiny one he just called me out of the
blue like yo I need your help and I like
that I like the fact that he had
confidence in my gaming that he would
pull me in and and we working it out but
whatever that it went left because of
some other dude that was in there I want
to give a shout out to at a attic and I
gotta say this because he is and when
credit is due
he is the only person I see run that dog
phase oh wait no he runs it yo he run it
like it's a game of Assassin's Creed
it's he's a beast with not being detect
like all the stealth LLC - get lost
often we love cuz that part is the first
time well get it I won't get to cuz I
know this is attics topic but we go get
into that but that is a very also when
destiny went down this week I found
myself like I don't lost like a lost
child it's been you know almost 100% you
know been rocking that you know tempted
to raid you know to get to them damn
dogs and you know that's where things
kind of broke down after I mess with the
dogs I've been able to get you and
everyone else I know our schedule has
been complete Alice's so it's been it's
been a big big Daisy I know how the now
like guaranteed on yeah we're gonna get
it done we're gonna get it done as we
definitely got to get that pop in and
get the plane what's going so we got
that but um surprisingly and I'm gonna
be really sure like I wasn't gonna pick
it up cuz I'm like you know in a County
my you know I don't know you know this
information like I'm like what is I just
dive my face in there and oh no nor me
so it was like I think it was a perfect
storm because I was getting home one
night and then they did a comparisons
video so I put up a comparison video
ahead what's right I'm like it was ID
yes and I'm like oh I got I got a big
enough memory card
let me do let me do it download it I
have to meet y'all I know most you guys
ain't 2k guys like that but like and one
of the things about 2k for the hardcore
2k people like one of the things about
2k is that my pop my player / my career
right standards like dues pump thousands
of ECE and they practice and they play
that game all the time the fact that you
could take that on the goal I was
blazing and then I was like let me see
how to 5vs5 gold is they had all the
animation evidence
no no stuttering no frame breaks all the
characters inside the crowd commentary
the cinematics just I'm like wow you
know you may have the best version of
that game right my son
for this reason only did you see the
reddit post and the post that's going up
about the game and the corrupt files no
I did not tell me all right
young Chris young Chris purchased the
game he spent $60 in VC points at
building up his character he the game
froze on him he went back into the game
we started as a spy I went back into the
game
they said file corrupted he lost all his
points oh no he called Microsoft you
know and it's not a Microsoft issue it's
a he a issue so it was and he brought
the premiere edition $100 Edition so he
called he a spoke put him on the phone
and I said they liked it I wouldn't be
surprised if they said it was
Microsoft's a spirit like Razak
what they did was Judy yeah they try to
uh bump him back and forth in between
well he got back on with Microsoft and
got the money back now um he started
checking post on Reddit and you know he
sent me the link and stuff like that of
other disgruntled guys on Twitter yes it
seems to be a corrupt file thing going
on and it's not just isolated with Xbox
is on PlayStation as well
okay not one switch was palsy that one
Wow interesting
that's weird cuz I heard that a lot of
the corrupt not necessarily corruption
stuff but other kind of like quirks and
kind of bugs were affecting the game
across the board and like I was on game
facts last night just I wanted to see
what people were saying about the game
and they were saying like they we did it
was you know just a little like like
again bug buggy stuff and stuff not
necessarily working I don't know about
the corruption stuff but
so you haven't encountered any of that
no no I mean is I've had a false ability
only time I think I got one cuz my thing
is at the end of the day it's always
generally with the history of 2k it's
always been those damn servers no
disrespect to today for what I do I'm
attack you know they try to hide me to
get their servers going let's just say
that off-the-record
[Music]
infrastructure is not the greatest not
even proof over the years take two of
those guys and even prove you know it's
just one of those things that 2k it's
always been known for that so I'm
getting like internet mindset and
they're just like all there exactly so i
minimize it like you got to kind of take
that l on that let me see but when I
know I'm not getting I did a three for
three I did a5 b5 I did and the whole
game is really online cuz they're gonna
do to my career all that stuff saves to
the the uploads to the 2k servers
anything you do you get VC or you you
earn badges or whatever you do it all
goes up there so you know if I'm not
from a technical standpoint I've been
counted no which I think maybe one drop
but I know for a fact it was a server
issue and I'm saying
and that wasn't doing it like me walking
around in that open world thing that
they got going on now so we'll see you
know I know it's early you know the
stuff is coming out but you know so far
so good but like I said if you're a fan
of basketball or you're a guy who's a 2k
fame this is an arcade console perfect
port of 2k on the go it is extremely
impressive and shout out to gaming for
doing that woman and I'm not they got
there is having that launch on the same
day as this counterparts if they don't
fix there's gonna be issues yeah cuz the
physical is not the physical is dropping
like they do it or like Wolfenstein
stuff it's digit if you buy digital you
get it today came out like that's still
better than it coming out like two
months after the other counterparts
because yes issue like you mind that
having done party clearly it's nice that
it's there but it's like if you buy it
on another platform to play it on day
one what's the point
no that's a valid argument you can't
deny what you say you know so it's it I
like that they went to digital route
with the same day and you know me
personally we got a lot of guitarists in
the show so we're gonna get right into
Salaam Lord song sendou had a no showing
today what's going on in the world of
grandpa last week we talked about how
you know grandpa hats a momentum going
into October and they also had some
challenges about you know in terms of
stock for the system their online
infrastructure what was gonna happen
Virtual Console they had some challenges
that they needed to sort of meet or sort
of overcome to be successful this
October so following week they had a
September Nintendo Direct where they
talked about a lot of the stuff coming
out for the rest of the year and into
maybe like the middle of 2018 and I have
to be honest like it's for the most part
it's really impressive I'm a little I'm
a little upset that there's so much 3d s
stuff cuz I just want them to just focus
ya know my 3ds a long time ago and I was
I was looking for one I'm like should I
get one just to play my nice like make a
switch port to like I feel like that
metro to good on switch but it's it's
it's bothering me hope they bring it
just it baffles me it baffles me i
understanding wanna sell the 3ds version
hopefully a couple of months down at a
time no 44 issues you're helping build a
brand that's already well-established
and taking away from a brand that your
help building it's like I just don't get
but you know I think the vibe is also
yeah I think the vibes they just don't
feel like they're letting it go I mean
they must still be making money off
they're not letting this thing go like
when you get a Nintendo Direct for the
bones boy it's yeah and I feel them on
that I mean hey you know why give up on
honor on a fountain of money why are you
gonna do that but at the same time it's
just like put everything let's do that
so um yeah I'll ask you all the Switch
stuff that they announce is very
interesting they finally gave Xenoblade
Chronicles a release date it's in
December and we've talked about how
December can be a detriment to these
games but I think the fact that switch
is just its own thing and Xenoblade is
only on that system
I think we're releasing December's
firing it gives the distance from Mario
it's a true hardcore RPG I think it's
fine in December and you have Fire
Emblem warriors um and are kind of
almost virtual console not virtual
console with this over with the arcade
the arcade ports I mean it's it's a
start
and it's kind of cool I guess we get the
original Mario Brothers in September
they had original they had they had they
gave you all those 30 games and we
always said that was coming they're
gonna break that down some way shape or
form so this is no surprise there
um so let me see um yeah if I leave my
got a date for Skyrim with Skyrim by all
accounts is looking at it and we'll get
into the other Bethesda my second breath
of the watch me bows up the wazoo so I
know I know somebody's happy amiibos
left it right coming out freemium
experience to the extraordinary see what
else do we have
okay um yeah the I downloaded the demo I
don't know if you guys did for the
doctor path traveller the square unit
7200 rpm oh there's a demo for it I
played a little bit of it it definitely
has that old-school look and vibe um
the voice acting is not the greatest
that might turn me off it has a lot of
code of old-school like how dare you all
traitor you know it's like a very long
but I mean square RPGs have a way of
kind of subverting what you expect from
them as the story goes along the stories
usually pretty deep and pretty cool
that's all it takes to get me to pick up
it yeah yeah you're right and I think
that's the thing a lot of people have
insurance attacks or do you know 15 was
still good but you know they went away
from the turn-based and made it a live
based and you know his 15 was was worthy
of the Final Fantasy name but even 15 is
by far possibly one of the worst besides
the 13 yeah it's a big departure from
what people expect from Final Fantasy
and I think that's the wrong they're
gonna go with the big releases from now
on so I don't know that you get come
back to this turn-based old-school I
know type junior on the door fantasy
Brad won't go back to it but Tokyo RPG
that's the people who's doing it now
exactly so I think that's a that's
another big boon for Xenoblade because I
know blade does give you that sort of
classic JRPG experience um and they
showed more Odyssey which is looking
fantastic
they showed a whole bunch of new worlds
that game looks absolutely sick
and we heard that the download size is
something like less than six gigs for
those with which is causing an uproar in
these streets have you seen this expect
more I'm surprised you're not raging
like that because I know your your size
clean but it comes a video game like one
Far Cry primal came out and that [ __ ]
was like 12 gigs in Far Cry 4 was like
36 that I might argue what did you sell
what are you trying to sell me like that
you know they're like oh there's just
better compressing files now do you mean
to tell me they did such a great job
compressing well primal but they didn't
do it with the game wood primal which is
in comparison to previous far companies
yeah just you know people said it was an
average game there wasn't anything
special was fun but it and you know I
still have it
you know John picked it up I have it for
a you know since I shared it a library
with them and I still have not got past
the mid you scream damn sound like
looking people know this but rabbits is
two and a half years okay
Nintendo's worlds aren't that big
they're dense there's a lot of gameplay
in a small space for Nintendo stuff a
lot of these games don't have like CGI
cutscenes like no boys actually know
real boys act no cinematics and then it
had and even even then like just
Nintendo's products are always tight
yeah right down to how they compress the
fossil yeah could the game be bigger I'm
sure they compress the hell out of it on
to get it onto that cuz they would have
made that game would have been 122 gigs
absolutely they're late
on three cards a shout-out to Bethesda
for coming through and really supporting
this switch happy you know we'll get to
the here in a second but uh you know
when it comes down to it it's like look
like they don't do CGI cutscenes when a
lot of people don't realize is whatever
language is that CGI oh that game
supports they had to have a counterpart
for every language for every day longer
your discs
there could be seven different cutscenes
from seven different like we're gonna
get into a - yeah that's a great one
story okay looks on yeah so um before I
get into my favorite part of the whole
thing I will say also um well a lot of
Indies that are coming out to the switch
yeah it needs to come to this system
absolutely it does but a lot of Indies
wonderboy death squared and one other
game yes ocean home desert
Zelda like it that they sold more on
switch than all other platforms combined
and this is that we talked about this is
something that we saw I saw and I know a
lot Carlito grisly music this is the
this is the de facto platform for these
type of games if you give me an indie
game if you give me an indie game no
matter how beautiful it is on the xbox
of the PlayStation 4 it's gonna fall to
the wayside I'm not gonna give it to me
on the switch I'm gonna play it's gonna
get front billing on the switch
oh okay so now we get into my favorite
part what is the factor that's coming
through and someone that those third
parties know but surely they come into
the system look I tell you this doom is
coming to the you who's coming to
surprise me doom has been on the point
that I was a surprise I was I was
surprised because we know how grandpa is
with the family friendly you know this
is probably one of the worst games you
could get that so far away from family
friendly Wolfenstein and killing you
know what that surprised me it's like I
said it's cool that it's coming out I'm
glad that they're getting it but the
fact that it's coming out like maybe
anywhere from you know two to five
months later it's just like it took away
for the ecstatic thing if it came up the
same day I would say it's a huge thing
but thank you said look Nick these the
vendee the god Howard to this
[Laughter]
i'ma tell you exactly why I won't and
how this deal with Bethesda scrap hmm I
don't see how more games is crap but
I'll tell you this the fact that Doom is
coming doom I really I I really don't
care how it looks in the I wanted to run
a they get a run at 60 that game at 60
is phenomenal and it runs a seat when TP
if doom is 720p I'll go and say like I
don't really care about the you know the
frames per second but if I'm sorry but
you know going down in like 540 PE to
make it is 60 frames that's problems is
just it it's like we should be going
like downgrading for the 360 resolution
like that that is not accepted why would
you this which is more proper than 360
watch they succeed like yeah I could
like it's not like they acted like we
played a mobile game and then when it
comes to the Wolfenstein I get anchors I
mean I get addicts point about it not
coming out day and date but to me the
thing about it is and we talked about it
last week I think in the continued an
ideal situation for both
for all parties involved Nintendo
PlayStation and Xbox will be some sort
of cross they feature which wouldn't lie
why would you not go there the most
negative scenario possible why why would
you do that
Thanks did you we talked about this
before it's apples and oranges yeah I
have Wolfenstein pre-ordered on my xbox
and I'm not playing until it comes out
on the eggs like you understand like
this is an additional game like if they
give Mac the exact same game running and
looking well on a portable system but
I'm probably gonna pay $60 for it but
I'm saving that cross safe thing would
add even more value to both the console
game and the switch game I'm not saying
they could do that I'm just saying
that's an ideal situation the thing
that's important here it is people
support these titles regardless that
come out exactly exactly and that's why
I think the day and date thing isn't so
important yeah I don't think it's ever
gonna be the primary purchase you can't
release that three or four months later
would you know they said 2010 to early
2018 well you know they systems on the
Xbox one and ps4 and then complain when
you know maneet their exploitation
oh listen this is this is how the window
operates right they operate in a world
like let's say you go to a woman it's
full of people right it's a vacuum yeah
it's two people in that room
that only have switch but everybody has
everything else and even played these
games months and at a time
and they didn't got it but they're
talking to those two people that don't
have access to other systems and they
don't care if the game didn't come out
the same date as these guys because
they're talking to those two people that
only have access and its a couple of
million of switch owners so when you say
you launch Wolfenstein across the boards
on these other guys and these guys have
to wait two months later Nintendo's not
concerned with what's going on outside
of their bubble
what's going on inside I think that
actually I think it's even better for
the game that that happens because then
you don't have that game to game
comparison you don't have that wonder
one comparison same house that way Harry
the split they will they all can always
compare but it's like that it's one of
those things you said it's like think
about think about a game like Skyrim you
don't see like how many iterations of
Skyrim you have we had it still selling
like it's still you don't say if you get
into it the next topic but you know
Rockstar you know we'll get into that
like games like that you know it's just
no matter when they come out on win
version it's still selling but I
understand you guys come as far as day
in date okay first of all oh my not care
about you know two people out of a
couple hundred but but then I'm sure
cares also act an addict like those
games are not going to sell like we're
acting like these third-party games are
not selling these are proving grounds to
test to see these are games that's been
out already they just want to see how do
they sell to this market if it sells
well in this market then yeah great
I completely agree yeah absolutely and
shout out to Perez
all the way in it'll do that to me is
the coolest part about it it means that
the door is open obviously with the LA
noire also coming out when it came when
they announced it was coming out for
Xbox and the PlayStation 4 so what if it
is it nine dollars because that's what
the game is worth stop giving me this
old crap prices say you are now so what
I didn't make it in the last one if they
want my patronage they have to cater to
me I can't see you
for K 60 frames-per-second words in a
wolfenstein on November 7 you know the
reason why mine is other games that are
coming out brother is talking about you
better mind your words because with me
too
there you go you back so you got some
static you want to finish cut your cut
now you are exactly what was the last
thing I was saying some about Nintendo
Wii so many timing of software something
like that launch its a reverb in the
background that's kicking in from yes
like you can hear cream before you like
is weird
yeah it's like reverb and then it kicks
in normal after five seconds you know
what we get the load remotely so we'll
deal with it but um if that's that I
mean if there's anything else you want
to get into on the direct or should we
move forward
no to me that was the most the coolest
part about that is the fact that again
hopefully these games start coming out
if they can fill in the empty spots
between Mario when there's no play
start off now next we got the director
lark is showing from director and I
guess I just felt like just for me
before finish I felt like it was a shoot
like not I grew a lot like not
everything in that directors for me I'm
gonna be honest right but it has such a
version that direct with that for me but
one thing I liked is a huge variety time
it almost over on me I'm not gonna say
you know title for title at the Xbox
show because I'ma be honest like yeah I
know I was not a huge fan I wasn't the
hugest fan and now that I take a step
back you get the emotion out and you
look out of it see for me personally it
wasn't but for the masses I can see how
there was a little something for
everybody right there was a Dragonball Z
fighter for this you know I'm saying
this group and that group the Ori group
you know blah blah blah anaphors the
guys or whatever with the switch I felt
the same way
not everything there was for me but
there was at least three or four that
was for me and then we got release dates
for a couple of big titles that I don't
know when to normal and to be the
biggest thing that was announced off I
don't know if touch now I'm sure is that
Mario bundle come out openly right now
and say I called it everyone else said I
said you were the first say that I
didn't think they would do it I said why
would they do it this that title is
gonna sell and for them to do that it's
gonna leave me get to my next time which
is a favorite talent the NPD's
[Laughter]
the chief job you know because having
the app has been updated oh Lord I
forgot about that
yes the grandfather goes down every in
the world is using so don't bring that
up we bring it up you know we thought it
was something that should be of this
generation but we will move forward so
like I said Tendo switch has announced
to be the number one console in August
which means that now for the past six
four out of the past six months
Nintendo has outsold the ps4 and Xbox
one in sales what I found interesting
though was Basava see besides that was
that the software line because I'm like
okay let's look at what's the top ten
games right what was pushing the
hardware out here what's going on so
look at that's we supposed to see that
you know I'm saying Xbox also you know
I'm saying has EA and pocket with that
and you know what's going on with that
grand theft auto how impressive is that
grand theft auto still charge and oxygen
victimless
top the top five you know uncharted you
has for tool again cell that just came
out let off you got a little you've got
the boot on his head hard you gotta let
me go get dizzy back so we got you know
Ramos makes Mario Cart you know call of
duty of mine will crash in overwatch so
I just thought it was interesting so I'm
sitting I'm on ok from a Nintendo stand
because obviously you know solve an hour
at that switch gang we coming into that
big showdown November with you guys
they've been in each segment with a hip
hop and PG and everybody that's got
actually could you be doing a segment
where you guys gonna bring the knee
right cuz I'm like spittoon would for
Zelda's fine which is still impressive
to be in the top ten and Madden is
number one in is not on their console
Grand Theft Auto is number two and it's
not on their console and it just I just
wanted to bring this to life I feel
about that that they didn't they don't
have the big triple-a release that's on
their platform yet are still winning and
PD the floor is anyone who wants to grab
I can tell you hmm
alright the way that they win is their
base purchases all their games so if you
are a Nintendo owner and Zelda comes out
98% of all Nintendo system owners is
going to purchase that game
if you're a PlayStation owner you have a
diverse viewing angle of things certain
games come out you don't even know those
games came out right
chances are if you buy an xbox or you
want to play a diverse against you
buying the Tindall product you want to
play a certain set of game fair game
okay but how is it beating man and man's
number one man but hey the thing Madden
was bundled with the Xbox well they have
a bundle how is the switch beating that
that's the thing that's clear is to me
because how many people purchase madam
you see you got to look at it that way
opposed to the isolation of the Nintendo
people think that the isolation is a bad
thing it's not for Nintendo and
Nintendo's aspect because you purchased
them there is a very specific reason
that you purchased this system what they
drop like like when you purchase a
Nintendo 3ds that Metroid I'm
guaranteeing Metroid is gonna chart next
month
it's going to charge so hard next month
that it probably went
MPD's next month because people are
holding out for these games madam I
didn't get mad at did you buy matter I
picked up man only 58 accessing a strike
as hip hop when he came Williams ride
let me give it shot did you pick up the
whole thing you matter you just on the
trial no I picked up the whole thing and
then I'm supposed to start elite with
the multi for shout out to the multi for
this guys we have a league going you
know so I did I said let me get it but
okay so one person out of this podcast
purchased it but everybody in this
podcast purchase Zelda right that
explain I'm adding to being number one
in the world for MPD I'll be done a
world but in us folks we're not talking
about a big title game we're talking
about Madden a yearly wrong game bro
Madden is huge minimize this people not
skip out on man yearly and get the one
after that turf all right here we go
again we have to start pleased to have
to stop talking about things
yeah listen you know I let lost art get
in you know I just thought it was
interesting I don't know how I'll be
honest I'm kind of bad but I was
actually surprised but I didn't think
they had a champion honestly you know
what else is an other month to September
I was we know destiny right so that's
huge
now I would expect PlayStation 2 right
right now let's listen up because we all
agree September how the Lord feel like
with the destiny number one number one
merciless awful we gotta guess that
right
we've gotta guess that that see here's
the thing though okay here's the thing
the destiny bond was only the pro bundle
to my knowledge they do not know base is
just a pearl that's a good that's a good
point soft feeling on on the maddening
then we'll do at the end of second man
what do we feel about you know whatever
the who's gonna win next month based on
testing stuff let's solve I want to get
you what do you feel what do you feel
about doesn't surprise me it's just
every year like again I mean that circle
we're having bought the show for a
couple of years and I'm sure there's
plenty of people that feel that way but
as a whole across the world those games
are always gonna sell and they this is
the this is Madden's month you know in
like Call of Duty belongs to you know a
November Bella's call duty like it just
happens in terms of the switch winning
to me either in retail anchorman calm
yourself
what is he talk about all the way
I just think you know the switch people
like we've said before when big games
are gonna come out you're gonna start
seeing stock in the stores everybody who
bought a switch at you know hardcore who
wondered switch early on has it already
now is the people that they were waiting
on it took a wait-and-see attitude
people starting to shop for Christmas
already for their kids and their
families
picking up switches stuff like that so
that's why are you gonna see the you
know systems selling and again winning
MPD that's the only reason it's winning
MPD without a big game attached to it
and it's gonna keep the outer Novus
genius on their part holding back
consoles because that's what they're
doing they're holding back until a game
is about to release and they hold him
down so they could bundle stuff up and
then you know when the surge when the
buying surges come the consoles will be
there to be purchased so that's that's
all it is honestly um it'd be
interesting if they win MPD next month
hardware wise that's gonna say a lot
because again like we were saying like
those hardware bundles for destiny I
don't see anybody beating destiny on the
software front but right the hardware
should also because of destiny to k2
case a beast and I remember looking at
shout out the Lord ain't going this and
Laura looking at them MPD's in two case
by the only titles that's consistent
throughout the entire year it just never
falls out of the top three the four like
in Lent till the new one comes up in
this neighborhood thing is going to push
it so far it that has been probably as
for sports the biggest new things I mean
I know Madden is doing that you know
that that story thing the longshot and
it was good I liked it it was nice it
was very good it gave me a look I said
I'm probably picking up on the price
drops but this 2k neighborhood thing is
so RPG ish mm-hm that US guys who play
rpgs if you go to your
in you touch you might be intrigued
enough to play basketball this year and
just play in the neighborhood and don't
even play the other aspect of the game
so they opened it up to a whole broad
section of people that weren't going to
pick it up before you know what it is
looking and now that I got it for the
switch what makes it amazing is that it
remove it they're simulating the days of
like me you shout out the Lord oh you
know I'm saying Lord King not black
magic we used to go to the five you know
say and we used to play a brotherhood
and 61st and this you got your crew of
your personalized hell is in you is you
and your people you know I mean so it's
like this this open world quest game of
you really building up your man and your
skillset and everything you do gets
rewarded and it's like it's it's really
well done it really makes you feel like
you just up-and-coming baller simulation
quest game yeah it's really well done
but on yeah back to back to your saying
uh what's up yeah and again and you guys
think you know locational laugh but
those switch sales are gonna help that
MPD number so you mention the two K's of
beats is gonna be even more of a beast
because you're gonna have a you know
however many thousand sales on the
switch it's gonna hell no this is true
listen I get it Mike every last one of
my children will have a switch Christmas
that's that's already done that's a done
deal so and then I saw the bundle I was
like well I can all have Mario's get
them all you know switch with Mario that
that bundle sounds great for me and
shout out the Lord addict he called it a
long time ago I didn't think and I tell
you this with that bundle with that
bundle
I can see certain retailers bundling in
another game from early on in the year
it doesn't have to be Zelda it could be
something small it could be Bomberman or
something like that or Tetris or
whatever party
so uh so what what are the Lord stick
further I get addict on this he's good
at it honest
yeah so all my questions so what are the
laws are we gonna do a little prediction
for September obviously we said you know
what we think it's got to be between
destiny and 2k right for September right
so what do we think on that console
front can't does doesn't intend to keep
it up with the switch does the ps4 pro
bundle push it enough with Sony I'm
seeing like NBA players and people on my
timeline talking about y'all get your
destiny squad together like I'm seeing
craziness I've seen it's in the winning
next month it doesn't matter what kind
of software you put on consoles I
already have 30 million plus of a
following when a new product is still
growing right I'm gonna flip this back
to the two Lords in second so what makes
you guys so confident is it the fact
that the Xbox one extra hard core the
new guys for November what what did you
guys feel is the de-facto point that's
gonna give you guys to bend in these
segments to get Nintendo to lose that at
Morphin November because the only thing
Games Black Friday Black Friday bundles
and um the Xbox one X that's the only
new heart witness when it comes down to
it in people you know games are awesome
games keep people on consoles but
hardware when people talk about hardware
don't even a that should attach to and
people will get excited I mean look at
look at that Apple announced a
thousand-dollar product that people are
flipping out because it's it's it's that
product nummy I shared the load with
these are the chances that talk about
how distasteful the ps4 card bundle look
see that excitement for the 3x and new
hardware that's that's what you're going
with
yeah I mean when you go down to it it's
like look I can see them getting
anywhere from you know 500,000 to a
million extra cells just off the apps
and that's me under balling it and if
they get higher than that we're not even
talking
yes if you put the s with the eggs those
two products together with Black Friday
and I wouldn't be surprised if you see
retailers you know $200 for an S with
with shadow of war bundled with it on
Black Friday we just talked about this
one on tickle our castle and shout out
the camera at the anchorman
you know what do we think would be the
best bundles for uh for the X and I
think Carol made a point I mean I think
I went with Assassin's cream shadow of
war and you know the third one you know
maybe they do it for Nagle Black Friday
pick what you want kind of deal and
rightfully buy it in the destiny to
information to come out but these Asians
I hate to say this Wolfenstein is the
best one that's what that's what that's
just because you know Wolfenstein is
going if you bundle that one native it's
not even that it has nothing to do with
what it's running at it's the fact that
you're boning a game that is coming out
around the same time the X comes out
that hype going out you can't bundle
games after it comes out you can't even
if destiny to came out in September
people acted like destiny to is gonna
help Sony window vembur MPD's like what
like by then know what like it's like
obviously no one's not gonna care about
destiny to we're still gonna play it but
for the most part you know we're a lot
of the cashiers are gonna leave destiny
to buy then they're gonna be playing
other games and it's just go be the hard
one base like you can't like you know
maybe Assassin's Creed is a little bit
better because it's closer to the launch
but for the most part you're right it's
got to be Wolfenstein because yeah at
the same time Assassin's Creed also also
can sell on its own like Wolfenstein is
as great as Wolfenstein 1 and a new
blood the old blood were they still are
if they don't appeal to the masses like
an assassin's creed does it
credo do fine on its own bundles at
Wolfenstein so a lot more people could
see how great those games are even about
the the condition of the game it's it's
about good I think a Madden bundle would
be the safest but I think a Wolfenstein
bundle and the last bundle put it three
months of games packs of game kill s yes
I for the most part I think they do now
Call of Duty and Star Wars that week
they need to have a bundle where you
pick your own game from the Xbox Live
digital market it's a combat the the
Sony marketing deals but I mean besides
that wolf inside I just don't see how
well you know promoting something after
it already came out because for the most
part let's be real here most people are
not waiting for an X to get a game
that's already out no one's waiting two
or three weeks to if they are about
Assassin's Creed like that they're not
waiting I am waiting if there are shadow
board like that they ain't waiting I'm
you know what the masses
you know it's alloys adequate let me
take my emotions out right there's going
to be people that I'm not wait for those
thing I can wait for C bomb yes he was
something I'm a huge shadow of mordor
fan and I'm a huge Assassin's Creed fan
I've played every Assassin's Creed and I
beat every Assassin's Creed but that but
you shut up shop tool evicted a chat he
was like what if they do
cuphead team cops oh my god don't play
with an appeal to the kids and appeal to
the kids for the most part you're not go
see kids having an axe yeah I would say
Lucky's tale I would say Lucky's tale as
it is that would be a lucky tell you
know but comes out this month
like I posted on Twitter I would have
loved to get a hard copy of that game
with a premium bundle with cuphead and
mug man statues out of that in an
artwork book and I would have paid off
which is the 250 for it
I think they should really go back and
revisit that aspect of it and you know
get out at least you know five thousand
copies of it at least or less than that
probably and ship that out and see if it
itself but I know it itself I will
purchase it and I would I would love to
have that but I already pre-ordered my
digital for the yes is interesting so I
mean it's this is gonna be I think this
is a fun time you know I just I just
could to switch out sell Xbox in
November this which could also both of
them in November when it comes down to
which double it sells to carbonate for
that for the ex that that's what it
comes down to it can they double
themselves in one month this is one
thing another thing and one of the
biggest thing that's gonna come down to
it is can they meet the demand for Black
Friday right can they accommodate to
that kind of demand you're right and one
thing like I said you the thing I think
you guys got going is we know the
hardcore Xbox guys are buying that and
that's still huge you know that's still
about old people who bought the original
Xbox one day one edition a lot of those
going to be repeat customers because the
people who bought day one or chances are
they're gonna buy day one on the X but
this is my question that we don't know
how many what that number is what's that
number
that's the question that was the Xbox
one actually it wasn't a request
MPD's murder was a million it was one
point six okay you got to see a
wonderful PD or the very now everybody
that purchase on launch day Xbox one was
that a day one edition whether they had
one regular ones so all we're getting on
bond today for the X is there weren't
additions right we're not getting any
base Xbox one X
a lot of stores this old why the school
Dobie Scorpio editions in regular
editions that's it I thought that all
the orders that have been regular Xbox
because they're going like this Mont at
the end of this month
Oh correct okay all right so we've
beaten this NPD thing down you know I
love my NPD so we had to bring it to the
table have some fun with it we are going
to move on so um I don't know if
anyone's been aware this is a group
topic here that um actually uh Microsoft
just announced some new tech and um it's
called intelligent delivery and pretty
pretty interesting man especially we've
been talking about the ex a lot when
talking about 4k assets and how big
these games are so I want to bring this
to the roundtable anybody get a chance
to look check out the article we did
found you stuff got locking sound like
you wanted so I'm gonna give it to you
on top of the stuff I've been talking
about this stuff for years the fact that
a lot of these are downloads are these
92 gigs is because you're downloading
all the languages in different all
cutscenes at different languages all the
languages of the Football announcers or
the basketball announcers you're
downloading all this insignificant data
that you don't actually mean it takes -
off to be innovative in this aspect
especially if it's 4k textures - that's
long that's huge but see this is what
happens when you build an ecosystem that
comprises of um old tech and new tech
whoa the low tech does the 1080p aspect
and they need those textures there's no
need to have 4k textures there because
they can't use it and the new tech does
the 4k and they need it and they don't
need the old tech so you don't need to
download those gigs so Microsoft went in
and they developed a system that that it
identifies what is necessary and what is
unnecessary
and as far as text goals as far as
voices goals you can say to your system
that I only want the English versions of
this and it would bypass all that other
stuff and just give you what you need
and that significantly lowers the gigs
that are taking up the space on your
system because we're running out of
space here
and Microsoft sees that as a problem
hmm facts this is a huge Lourdes Lourdes
RV want to jump in on you so I think
it's fantastic I mean I honestly like
what King said like we're running out of
space I'm over here you know on Amazon
looking for a terabyte you know exams
obviously with all these new games
coming out and everything you know with
the higher quality assets coming out on
the X you're gonna need more space and
this space is gonna run out very quickly
so uh yeah I mean big up to Microsoft
for this my only worry with it is that
they implement it in a way that's very
user friendly so it's not full of like a
lot of technical jargon and that the
system handles it like the way he
presented is very easy and you can say
look when you put yeah when you manage a
game it needs to just straight up come
and say do they need to be like 10
options there which ones you want yes
which ones you don't want to keep ain't
got campaign exact languages divided up
in a way that's very easy for the end
user to use and I think it'd be
fantastic I mean to be honest man a lot
of people will hate on Xbox honestly
don't don't really realize the additions
to gaming that they've made over the
years they've innovated back a lot of
what we consider to be regular gaming in
this day and age you know with you know
with the online infrastructures and
stuff like that Microsoft was a
different state through that don't you
get enough credit that HDMI pass-through
in this Xbox is probably the single most
important innovation in this system it
allows
for intelligent use of your television
and your other devices to go through
your xbox that's yeah huge and it
functions with that what's good about
that is that it doesn't need the cable
box anymore because more and more people
don't use cable the fact that you can
you have the your antenna receiver and
you can still do the DVR functions with
over-the-air signals
that's huge it just creates again it
creates an ecosystem for all of their
products and it allows you to use
everything in a very smooth and
functional way and again to me my only
caveat was this make it easy to use and
it's gonna be fantastic
and I'm sure Playstations gonna benefit
from it also what do you feel once just
got announced intelligent delivery how
do you feel about it I mean it's like
you got Seth I really feel like this is
this is definitely an aspect that no one
really gives Microsoft credit for you
know they want to keep going at them for
you know everyone including myself as
what then at them for exclusive games
but when it comes to software they're
second to none in fact they got the best
software engineers in the world so I
mean you know we could go at them all
day for everything and everything else
but it's like you know I was playing
destiny too and you know I could I could
not get people together everyone was
doing something else so I was trying to
do a nightfall with anchorman and this
is before we sent a lord cow an invite
to the party and I was about to use lfg
like and it's simple you make a post on
lfg especially raids you make a post
about race on lfg you got an entire
six-man fire squad in about 15 minutes
if that yeah that's huge that's huge
that's one girl talks about whatever I
say people always like well Playstations
got that too playstation doesn't have
integrated into the UI yes that's that's
the key that's huge you don't have to go
outside learning devices might want you
to play here the moment you know and it
pops up when they notify you'll pop up
saying this dude's interested in your
post you'll hold it and the cool thing
about destiny is because you know Mike
you borrow you
Lord we are pretty much on the down-low
told me Lord Cognito it was made with
the ideal of destiny remember that
absolutely hate it when you look at
destiny to how it works on destiny to
when someone's interesting and you click
the middle button you bring up their
profile and it says if you accept their
interest or not it actually tells you
what light level how long they play what
kind of time they have in the game and
so you know that they built you know
destiny to lfg around the ideas of what
we would want to look at before we let
people in our group mm-hmm this is this
is great stuff I mean when I when I
heard about this and again shout out to
tick podcast last night I was running as
a guest and Kara made up some good
points in and also look basically in
conjunction to what Lord King is saying
it's like Microsoft does not get enough
credit for these things that they
innovate you know strums or Xbox Live
and in services and software and
backward compatibility is so many things
and this is just another one to the list
I think is really cool like for me
personally I just think is something
like I just think of a game like Gears
of War I here's what I played I'm gonna
keep it 100 shot gun shooting game type
D multiplier it's just not my style
no shout out to the people who play it
who are hardcore with it I've just years
a war for me is campaign and horde mode
those are my that's my gears right here
next to me for me hold it that's that's
that's big so it's like to have that
option before I pick up the game and be
like okay boom I'm leavin God just
uncheck bow tie play this will not be
download take that 30 gigs or whatever
it is away from me like I mean you know
go necessarily on that it's like once
you play Halo 5 you play the story once
88 dozen of hey every 8 percent of story
orientated games at all besides maybe
lenez's the games it's a one at done
thing if there's no war more than one
time on the majority of games you only
play once on let's be real you play it
like you know titanfall
titanfall was an amazing game hype r2
had a phenomenal story I only played
that once delete note No
for me mm-hmm yeah I mean these are good
points I mean think about like you've
got huge like halo is like almost a
hundred gigs I read downloaded it for
that for that for the X I'm doing all my
like I'm getting all my X Games no I was
prepping them because I want to see how
the X is gonna take it to the next up
I'm looking at these games I'm like
these things are ridiculously big so
this is a really cool feature I like how
they also talked about the download you
know speeds and stuff like that instead
of requiring a game you know they saying
that you know multiple server client
connected to the internet when it games
too big for one disc multiple discs
could be separated between essential
data and optional chunks and they also
talked about potentially getting third
parties you know involved with this
process as well and I think this is
really cool but people like that's
opposite of me that hey like hey they're
not even gonna play a single play all
they want to do is play a multi play on
a certain game they got the option you
know in in the 4k assets and the last
point when the make was that what I
found surprising I didn't know because
again we got a lot of these armchair
developers out here on social media
acting like they know how games are made
and stuff like that I didn't even know
that when you pick up a lot of these
games they have all these languages as
part of it you know new so now that they
can add these tags in the software
Microsoft can add these tags in the
software to say okay he you know Lord
King and these guys are in the US region
intelligent delivery will automatically
say okay they don't need the Polish we
don't need to see what a lot of people
don't realize is the file size between
720p and 1080p is a really really
significant like especially from 1440p
to 4k we're talking probably two or
three hundred gig games exactly now you
bring in 4k into the picture with 4k
assets and how big those days they told
my for the 7 is over 100 you don't mean
this is this is huge text shout out to
the Microsoft on a platform guys you
know they're doing they're killing it
out there you borrow a shout out to all
those guys what Lord still well you know
it really doing a fantastic job they
don't get enough credit and it's good to
see Microsoft innovating once again
so I thought this was a really cool and
the last one I want to make is that
shout out to them going using digital
foundry as their mouthpiece I think
that's the smartest they've done with
the Xbox one X because we all know
ledbetter comes up you know when they
did guys - you can tell when you were
stationed down your right um you know
shout out to you because I don't know if
these guys are looking at what you
posted but um the bump up on a DVR the
detect that they're bringing before this
X comes out they're raising the tide
like you know everybody eats when when
the tech is out there and it can be
shared through this ecosystem and trust
me I know
after this X is released it's only gonna
get better yeah absolutely this is great
stuff y'all so shout out - did you
foundry in the Xbox team for bringing
this information to us but we are going
to move on so Lord yes some laughs I it
didn't talk you wouldn't bring to the
table what's going on I wanted to talk
about the Leviathan raid that just came
out last Wednesday for the most part you
know I wanted to go over the section so
if anyone in this podcast wants the raid
to be completely you know blind this you
might want to mute this part but this so
like I think the only person here who's
really done as much as I have is Lord
King yes sir
but for the most part the rate is great
I like it I like the mechanics behind
the Ray
I still think taking Kings better yeah I
just enjoyed the taken King more I
thought you know goals cool but I don't
do you guys care if I tell you who the
boss is
um most no but do you care Lord sauce no
he's a robot
okay it's not go it's mostly to the
Emperor but it's not the Emperor it's a
robot
it's callous but what they're trying to
show you is if you finish it um callus
has multiple giant calluses like what
you think maybe that there's multiple
the Phaeton's throughout the galaxy and
this guy is out here here running amok
all over the place you know do you get
to the real Calais we don't know maybe
that's in the hard race we have
absolutely no idea uh this rate and I
I'm glad I could talk about it right now
I have to give attic his props Lord
addict I stayed in his hip pocket okay
now I showed him one aspect on the the
babes you know the dad hated yes and the
bathers if you do the system that I
adapted that that week is you know we
learned it and I adapted this system if
you do that system is easy you can do it
in one run Lord addict came and showed
me his system for the dogs and shout out
to IOP we innovate baby we put this out
here this dude runs this like he's
Adrian Peterson in his prime
I was in his hip pocket we did it and I
said this guy is a mastermind he is a
complete genius beast in the hardest be
part of the rage this is the hardest
part
don't get it twisted this part where you
have to build up the pollen and you have
to you have to hit multiple plants in a
given amount of time he's found out that
don't sneak he runs he doesn't crouch
down and hide this guy is wooden past
the dogs and cuz he knows certain things
and I said you know what I was so
fearful and doing what he did and he
took the initiative the same effort i'ma
try it and it worked and if you look at
his attic show he posted it we're up
there because we ran it with him shout
out the sinister Lord sinister
check out his video to see how he did it
and then go and look at everybody else's
video online I'm telling you this nobody
does it like him
nobody bczp so I want to jump in yeah I
mean we started it you know we got to
initially the from day one to the
bathers you know I got caught out there
cuz the system that we had initially you
know the thing about this raid that I
will say off the jump first of all let's
get back to me in my opinion out of all
the destiny and I'm a destiny hardcore
out of all the destiny rates this is the
greatest introduction to a raid I have
ever been a part of it is absolutely
glorious the way you enter the raid um
from an aesthetic standpoint it is
stunning it is very Imperial it's very
legal it is Emperor Callas welcome you
to his domain so yep it is just a
beautiful thing it is not to support too
much loss up the budget the beginnings
you can see they're so disrespectful
they don't even attack you you want to
pop off ready for what you think you
ready for so we gonna let you come in
and have the five an audience they first
it's like you have to have an audience
he has to prove that you're worthy so
it's almost like these trials that's
basically the gist of it right so you
know we got to debate this part and um
just it's real cool it's one of those
raids though I will say you know shout
out to our Lord Luke's Roseworthy I'm
gonna get you guys on ILP before I die
so the guy would love to talk ray be
honest with you guys and um raid it is
similar to the taken king in the sense
that it is very reliant on teamwork and
if put it this way it's the way that I
call your a job no no no no no yes right
it's your job
and if you mess up you gonna get called
out on it because it snitches on you oh
yeah the loot drops to suck but there's
a reason why they suck and I'm gonna
tell after everybody else goes exactly
why the loot drop sucks and why you got
a stick in it and the reasons why Bungie
did certain things in this raid I just
want everybody to flush out their ideas
and then I can you know like I said I
just want to too much I mean I feel good
right I do agree with I know what Lord
Eric's going I'm not gonna give it to
tell ya I'm gonna listen I'm not gonna I
did sneak sneak I looked at player
unknown and looked at Shadow Ball khakis
he had a great show man you know I'm
saying on a bond sis you know I'm
looking at these guys streams and it's
just so cool on day one to see the
hardcore guys try to figure these things
out on the fly and see the world's first
who gets it done that's one thing he's
doing good luck I still don't care man
some of these people they have some kind
of prior knowledge I just like it blows
my mind that someone beat the whole raid
in the time it took me being on the dogs
like I don't care you know I know Lord
demons real strong that you know that
that's just the aspect of their game
they hold sacred they don't you know
give anyone but you know coming from so
and that's gotten for you know press
release documents like you know when you
review a game they actually say on what
you're reviewing tips sometimes on what
you're doing and I just it's like you
know I'm looking at Goliath stream and
you know it
I wouldn't say like you know the
reactions to the mechanics are fake but
I'm saying that he is noticing stuff
that it took me an hour and a half to
notice what are too quick
true I understand we go in there and we
also have to say this we're at a
disadvantage guys a lot of these guys
are getting the game two days early so
they're getting the light level to 9300
by the time you know I'm saying like a
head of us so that's another fact that
you being stronger in a raid really
helps you know I mean like it's a
difference but it was something strictly
this this Ray doesn't have anything to
do with ads and except for the last part
a lot of ads in the boss but for the
most part John Lord John a 265 was doing
fine was doing fine
no I get it and it just goes back to my
initial point you know again it's early
we haven't you know I just sneak peek at
a couple of people screaming and stuff
like that shout out to Bungie for doing
a tremendous job with marketing the
whole world first and everyone's watch I
think that's great marketing you know
that when a ray comes out did they do
that
um just think for this right now again
it's early you got to compare it to the
Pantheon we got a company have to wait
for the hard mode to come out we gotta
wait for challenge more it's early
if they build the game revolved around
the the hard mode right down to the way
I right now I can't give it overtaking
king yet because the only negative I
have against it is I wish there were
more bosses like to meet this rage
screams for bosses like almost I was
thinking like uh what's that working
what's that old-school karate Flynn used
to watch Bruce Lee starts at the bottom
of the ocean I wanted more game of death
like don't get me wrong I saw it was set
up in a way that you could do the
wu-tang 36 chambers that's what I
thought it was gonna be like what was
the bald-headed monk that was in the 36
chambers um I thought every room was
gonna be a boss boss fight you know um
maybe it when you go laughs great raid I
suggest you guys do it you know who gets
to the proper light level I would say
getting me a minimum to 80 just to be on
the safe side taking more damage you
know run with ILP normal did vary scores
Channel five you know all these guys
grab GG all these guys that's running it
you know his new thing that's running
this thing and it's real fun but imma
let you guys get when when it goes to
the whole you know boss thing mentality
I am disappointed there what more boss
the thing that I know is me is the right
is huge it's like it's yeah you know
Laura Cognito Lord sovereign especially
Lord saw her he hasn't even been in it
you know lord kognito i've showed you a
little bit about you know the aqueducts
you know the sewer system it's bigger
than that it's bigger than you think
yep you know I was going around the the
map yesterday and I was like I ain't
even seen this ring I felt like they
should have had moments like in Final
Fantasy two where you walk into a
certain room in the basement and there's
a red ball that's just hidden secret not
not forced people you know tell people
you know a great challenge lanes of you
know awaits be are you sure you want to
enter the room so you know I felt like
stuff like that would have been better
you know dark so stay that dark so
staying where you know something's
coming it'll sort of warm your the most
part the mechanics are on point I just
felt like you know maybe after you kill
the dogs a big dog shows up and you know
like I felt like it was more about what
two or three people were doing and not
what everyone's doing in this raid hey
the only time that it was really about
like you know splitting up was uh you
know the dogs wasn't even really about
splitting up for the most part everyone
was on the same page but the last part
is about so splitting up like this they
don't just split you up lore Cognito
they take you to a different dimension
split you up yes no trust me I've
actually pkp streams you know all it
takes is one message I have learned you
know the dude that that is trying to
suck you into his mouth I have found out
that if you're the signal and you pop
you're super you can use your right
bumper and go back over yeah interesting
also your Lord Lord King you know when
we first saw you know something to do
the rate I just asked you or King go
then I'll talk about like new stuff and
my questions about like raids in general
okay cool all right
so check this out guys I'm gonna give
you a quick synopsis of the raid and the
reason why some people may feel the loop
sucks now
Bungie has taken all the aspects of all
the ways that they'd done and all the
data that they'd done before you ever
had the problem when you go to lfg and
you get a guy and he jumps in he steals
the checkpoint he jumps out that's not
gonna happen anymore all right the
reason why they eliminated that is if
you take your raid team to space and you
come back down you no longer spawn back
in that same room Check Point is gone
but not really the checkpoint is open
once you open up the aqueduct now the
aqueduct is accessible to you from the
beginning of the raid you have to go
downstairs you have to put in the
sequence 1 5 3 4 2 6 and the doors will
open upstairs you go into the aqueducts
now if you finished any raid boss or any
raid womb prior to going into the
aqueducts when you go into the aqueducts
that raid room is accessible to you so
you just have to know the path to get
back to that room now as you beat each
room you will get keys these Keys go to
chests that are located in the aqueduct
and gives you incentive to go into the
aqueduct and to go around and find these
chests these aqueducts is in this
Leviathan that is miles long actual
miles all right so you're running around
these aqueducts going to different room
and going to different chambers to get
to different parts of the raid now I
know how to get to the dogs I know that
the Pleasure Gardens I know how to get
to gauntlet and I know how to get to the
boss mom
Lord addict showed us how to get to
certain keys like the ventilation key
the drainage key the other keys that are
involved these give you loot drops all
right but this is not the raid loot
drops you can get lucky and get a gun
you can get lucky and get a hat or a
helmet but what
get is you get these medallions now of
no vendor will open up at the tower once
you completed the ra9 vendor you can
take those medallions that you got from
the raid and go purchase raid gear okay
so there's no longer are you just
running to get a chest in the raid and
you out no Bungie wants you to finish
this raid
you're not gonna get any credit for it
because if you look at the clan or notes
you notice if your box is checked if you
finish the rate if you didn't finish the
raid you're not gonna get the perks so
it's no longer jumping in stealing stuff
if I gotta boss silliness free stuff
it's free is over and you must finish
the raid at a hundred percent like let's
say somebody calls you in and you didn't
do the first part of the raid and you
just beat the boss you didn't finish the
raid the beginning what you missed going
in with this like time for the raid and
it's not six hours have a good team and
a good team can jewel the raid in under
three hours it's literally that easy
attic and I did the front part to the 20
minutes right 2025 minutes the first
part attic
yeah and took us like an hour and a half
for the second part exactly so we get to
an hour and a half inside the womb
because people was messing up in the
beginning and it's not Lord addicts
while he had a different method he
learned the new method and then it was
one guy that we had there that had to
learn how to do a raid it was his first
time in a raid and we were telling them
standing on the platform he was standing
someplace totally different so we wasted
at least an hour a half an hour there
doing that
once we got it down pat we beat it in
one shot we got to the dogs
and Lord addict had to train us if we
use already a r18 complete going in it
would have just took us 25 minutes or
half an hour to get past that part then
we have to go to the gauntlets every
part is all about time lengths easy you
see so once you know your place and
trust me this rate will snitch on you it
will say you messed up so you can point
the finger at that guy and end your
friendship with them
alright this this is the most
thought-out aesthetically pleasing raid
I have supported it looks beautiful
phenomenal and the mechanics behind it
has a purpose no more free stuff if
you're looking for free stuff this is
not it go play to taking King go play
careful they're gonna build all the
other rates with this aspect in place no
doubt law solve what do you have what
are your new questions before we move on
from this town who's never done or a
period in either deaths um my question
is like what is it about the Rey a that
makes it so special
and specifically what why is that why
does it require such coordination
because mama understanding everything
that I hear about the raid is that apart
from the gunplay it adds a lot of
different mechanics in terms of myself
mechanics platforming mechanics puzzle
solving mechanics my question is how is
this stuff incorporated like all the
puzzle stuff solving things going on
while you're fighting oh this is
something like like you clean out a room
and then you solve a puzzle is how you
find it okay did some sections like its
each raid let you finish much you finish
a question in an hour answer
no said I was it like basically what is
it about the raid that makes it so
fantastic and how is it like how is
there is there kind of a formula that
they use for the raise in general you
could tell somebody hasn't been in there
like look rates and compiz this sort of
this sort of thing I mean they recycle
sir
you know mechanics of a raid but for the
most part you know they might recycle a
certain mechanic what the room is
different you're doing something
different with that mechanic and not
necessarily what they recycle also loss
off it what makes it unique too is that
it is completely blown you may enter a
room or an area and the game does not
really give you any hints as to what the
hell you're supposed to do and you have
to really problem-solve look at
structures look at things look at
sometimes the only time they'll give you
clues is when you die and you'll see
some statements like how many this
killed or how many levers pushed or you
don't say like so you're like okay maybe
this is something towards this and they
put that stuff in the death screen or
rat people out basically each segment
sometimes have so many different type of
mechanics where they may split the group
up and say okay one guy has a tremendous
responsibility to do XY and Z which said
object right or you know the other four
may do this or they may split you up two
into three teams of two that have to do
specific activities then there's some
parts where it's just let's just fight
and get it on it's just something we're
okay let's team up to form Voltron let's
all stand on this way let's protect each
other and let's do XY and z so it's just
perfect combination the way I buy soccer
is a perfect combination of gameplay
mechanics fighting for the first time in
this one but we talked about their
stealth and that's what we given what I
call his price because that's never been
in a destiny right before okay that
Pleasure Gardens is something I've never
experienced mechanically from rain it
again it's extremely unique I didn't
understand what the hell was going on a
lot of youtubers when they've now beaten
it have still said yes calais was hard
the final boss but nothing is harder in
the entire rain than the pleasure garden
that's what that's the consensus I've
been hearing from the pot the tower so
that's just my assessment well I know if
you're thinking chef's like three hours
seems like a long
but in Destiny's hours three hours ain't
[ __ ] you can say that let's move over
quit me a couple tech now okay questions
um um so in terms of okay so in terms of
the different mechanics now how does
your class especially subclasses now how
does that affect how attraction in the
regression drastic drastic because this
some sections were certain classes just
Excel but if you have a hunter at some
part what a tenor and certain you know
you can do this if you have yeah the
warlock and he's healing people in a
physical space while you guys are taking
a tremendous damage you each class bring
something unique and there are some
sisters existences in destiny raids
where if you have a lot of the same
class I said yeah the Golden Gun hunter
you need a high DPS you know I'm saying
well you can he's through certain parts
if you spec outright you got the right
team like I've learned this new Lord
King you know or another thing is the
right weapon right back to the
Gjallarhorn games or like oh hold on
let's get to eight you guys sleeper
stimulant that's all sleep is stimulate
this guy with weapons of light and we're
gonna do double the damage multiplier
because we all got this like this
certain flows in weapon mechanics and
also add to it that you eventually find
out over time that can make things much
easier for you yeah like shout out you
know to lord Neil he's like you know
that's a that's a gun that if one
additional person has it equipped it
doubles the power of the gun up to six
so think about that in a rate and how
that could be useful for certain parts I
was even speaking with Lorne ear last I
said you know what we messed up when we
got to the to the bathers because
there's a part where they want the team
to come together and you guys shoot
through chandeliers I'm like warlocks
why we didn't just put our empowering
light on to give everybody high DPS and
then you put your healing rift on and
everyone's getting healed and doing
extra damage while we all kinda those
are shooters they will literally kill
all the ads for yes
I'm learning I'm learning so many stuff
people are telling me for the careless
fight shout-out to Lord Holtzman when we
get him on the show from on which got
the old Plank desta god s Negro
community podcast guys you know he's
like yo cold heart on callus is lik yes
I'm saying and that's what happens in
rate over time people start figuring
easier ways to do it and then like Lord
King said different methods like you
guys say I noticed you know you channel
five guys do it this way we do it this
way and the very first way you do a ray
Lord sovereign like six months later
before the next ride comes out that
right that way that you did a day one is
completely gone no one has it that way
anymore now waiting what becomes
obsolete yeah that that's how raids are
it is just what again I people get to
the point where it's not about doing the
right anymore it's about doing it as
fast as possible yes and efficiently and
I've tweeted it before and I know people
snow I'm a destiny fanboy I ride hard
for a wave that flag but in my opinion
that's neat to rate or the bet that
series are just the best cooperative
experience in gaming because not only
have you been challenged you form a bond
with whoever he was in that group okay
what you say and it can't be it
definitely could be a bad bond trust me
over a year and we played the Kings fall
raid I didn't remember him he was like
yeah we played the King full-rate begin
in the end it was such a great
experience I needed your help
I said wow wow moment in these times
where like those are about to say like
you may have a rocky group with you is
this you know people may get love some
people don't like the way they talk
people talk cuz you know act a while
like you know mistakes are gonna be made
and blame blame the people especially
because there's people who think they
know it all you know it causes all these
little funny things that happen during
the course of rhythm
and I will say this like shout out to
the race it sounded even really do you
know adding those guys like we started
off listen even an hour and me now are
going at it
video is going on today I could already
see they they had their theories okay we
need to do it like this no no you doing
it wrong we need to do it like this and
in like after tie like sometimes you can
split you know we get these ideas and
like okay let's try we said well let me
look online I'm like no let's not look
online let's try what we're doing you
need to look at each no I just want to
see the whole thing and I'm like I don't
get what you mean no because when you're
looking at it arrayed from someone else
doing it at the moment on YouTube you're
seeing it from one perspective here for
40 minutes watching someone do a rade I
don't want to I don't want a person
looking up YouTube to figure something
out while we're sitting in the red
because that's gonna take 20 to 30
minutes of our time where we can be
actually formulating our own plan I mean
I listen man if I can't stress the way
that I do is the way we do it now and he
would literally not listen to me but
shout out shout out to Lord Neil
y'all got it together during the dog
segment when you taught him how to do
the thing at the top he was getting
better shooting the light with the rock
on the gun if he put him up there
he has no confidence in him I definitely
do put people the people gonna come down
well we gonna talk about that here in
the second ship believe that you know
for the most part if I put people down
there it's the people I rely on the most
and not put the people I want one
reliable person up there and let me tell
you it wasn't it chopped whiskey to
whiskey actually I did throw Neil and
whisky up there not knowing what the
hell was gonna happen I'm not saying I
didn't know how that was it what's funny
is we
doing a raid in C dvd/cd was literally
the most useless person in the whole
raid we're sitting there oh he knows it
he I told him multiple times your youth
boat right so I'm still here you know
King David explaining what's going on
and I'm just like look I don't care what
you guys do I want sinister Porter Ark
and King down there with me you guys you
guys complain about who's sitting up
here that is not my business
so and then you know see these okay I'll
sit up here and I'm okay what do you do
dudes like I was like did you listen to
anything King did oh okay you're
hoarding the rock over there against the
corner sit down and so we tell you to
come out he also saw people have to
admit in rate when they don't know what
they're doing it they don't like to do
that but you have to say y'all I don't
understand this you will have to break
this down there's people in there who
just be freestyling and strike a small
version of a radio so it's 90 so strike
is this action is straight-up action
there is no kind of raid mechanics than
any strike that we had no mechanics is
just kill but on before I know it we've
exhausted this I do want to talk about
something briefly real quick okay go for
a loafer amy-jo games this gave me six
out of ten and for the most part you
know he and I agree if everything he
said I do agree with like 80% of
everything that man said I feel like you
know giving saying the gaming crude but
then at the at the same time saying that
I'm going to give it the same score as
the first one because they didn't
initiate to try to you know Brian out
make the game any bet you know it's like
they literally just did stuff that
should have been in the first one so I'm
gonna give it the same score I don't
really agree with that concept but do
you guys think that you should [ __ ] on
the raid because you can't do it that's
what I want to ask you guys do you guys
feel you should never just because
content is too hard for you personally I
don't feel or a person personally that I
don't feel that I mean look at the docs
old age right
those come the hardest stuff like that
in these DS are still considered you
know very you know high quality games
you know difficulties one things it's
kind of tough to scroll but at the same
time a site if you personally can't do
something I don't know how that affects
and if you see the little clips that he
puts in his video they're right there
they're like I spent six hours ad get
[ __ ] for this and and I'm building with
this I'm not going
that's loot drops no but that's
different loot drops is dish it's
because the frustration they they were I
didn't you did you watch your Lord
carnita there's not one quick pass the
dogs then then people got stuck on the
dogs Lord attic just like I told you you
have to complete the raid to get the
raid loop you might get lucky and get
something there it you can get actual
equipment from the chest but it has a
lower there's probably a 30% chance of
getting stuff from the chest now for the
most part they made it more casual
friendly in a way where you know if you
can't get to the whole raid don't worry
we got you is you got to do I want the
one time in time I will say they still
achieve Tommy's defense I kind of missed
the rat to the Machine she hooked us up
man but every segment of that raid when
you jumped around you got something it's
over
it did what you know what I what I was
hoping though I was hoping you have what
wrath machine did that I thought was
really good I was hoping for this one
remember when I had those Sivir things
and you actually transfer ten of them
into one key yeah and that kind of gave
you a reward or something I just three
with you know going from the formula of
making people addicted to it like
lottery tickets like that was definitely
not a good move but at the end of the
day I felt like they're trying to keep
the raise more relevant as long as
possible
rent so you know like they are they're
very one of those people it's like look
like we're gonna hook you up like don't
worry about you you're gonna get plenty
of loot we just as you beat the whole
rate one time beat it please because we
need to beat the whole raid one time you
open up the the extra vendor that's in
the tower and you feed him those tokens
and he just hands you right [ __ ] yeah
god I fed I think we've beaten grade too
definitely gotta move on no if you're
saying that uh that angry Joe made it to
the end no you didn't he said it
specifically in the review I don't even
feel like I want to finish the race so
I'll show you did he was definitely
trash at this game uh uh you know I
respect angry Joe it's like I said every
other point that he made in that that
review for the most part was fair
criticism but I doubt to look I miss and
I agree with what he said he says well
he didn't like the first one either
there's some people did that the other
day this is a man that didn't like
evolved because it was hard listen at
the end of the day so they shout the
Lord you know I'm saying oh what'd you
call it uh I met sin for that comment
that was really cool but let's move on
Lord King being keeping the Destiny
steam going I'm assuming we'll talk
about numbers are they considering it a
flop because the numbers have come back
and it's not the same as the first
Destiny and I attributed this to the
fact that the install base of the
PlayStation 3 and the 360 was huge so
when destiny released destiny released
to all four formats and this time it
only released on two formats but an
install base that is not as high as the
combined four formats that released two
at the first time now you got PC coming
next month so those numbers aren't in
there yet but these numbers that are
indicated are lower lower than expected
what was it a hundred thousand something
like that it was um they talked about
right now that it's it was less than the
100 and so 175,000 physical copies least
in the UK during launch week compared to
destiny once
417,000 arm physical copies so it was
more for sweet physical if you want my
honest opinion I'm sorry chief your you
his his YouTube partner be that their
stream was in the review I don't care
what some other man did it if you can't
review some what others as experience
we're not going to that anymore I feel
like for the most part when it comes to
this whole you know it was lower than
expectations I think the biggest
question is how much more are we under
estimating digital sales exactly the
reason why I have to point to the
digital sales is because they are saying
that at a given time there are a million
players playing the most play game on
xbox right now in fact that all right on
PlayStation because they don't combined
all right they don't combine so you say
the PlayStation probably let's say let's
split it PlayStation has 500,000 Xbox
has 500,000 million players playing at
one time so those digital stills has to
be incredibly high right so when the PC
numbers come out so is this considered a
flop because the the physical sales
aren't reflective yeah let me let me get
in on this I think I think this is the
thing where it's like unfortunately
would end I don't know if it's MPD is
company's number so I don't want to
throw anybody in the bus I don't know
this is what a point with us not having
digital sales being tracked is really
antiquated now and it's getting to the
point where as much as this gen started
off and everyone was being resistant
towards digital you know it is huge now
it is huge now and it needs to be
tracked so we can actually get a better
idea of how these games are really doing
you know now I think I believe MPD now
starting to include himself correctly
understand because I'm starting to see
yeah
Yeah right so now I know this report
came out for the UK I don't know I
believe they use some company called
short track but short track doesn't do
downloads like this UK cannot truly do
it until the companies come out oh you
know I get it it's a fun little thing to
say you know for the people who don't
like this I guess you know um I can't
well in this day and age not being able
to track digital sales I have to look at
it you know like okay those are the
physical numbers okay great but I can't
look at it as a complete picture of the
climate of the game you know I'm saying
or the temperature of the game okay this
is just the physical just gives me some
ideas of some things but you know that's
just what I saw lately that with it yeah
I mean I think they've been tracking
basically they announced that initially
in 2016 so they've been tracking for a
while and Activision is definitely one
of the companies that supports it so
like like Lord addict said not everybody
supporting it just yet so you're not
gonna get real real numbers for every
game um but it should this which this is
what strange to me maybe you look at
those numbers and it seems obvious that
they're only physical sales because you
haven't like you said so many concurrent
people playing that it's it has to be
more sales than that of so the fact that
Activision is supporting it but maybe
they're holding their head on destiny
until they get you know a month out yeah
so they have you know clearer rounder
numbers that they could show rather than
you know first with no me let's be the
game came out two weeks ago so right the
numbers aren't even back for them right
right
I'm sure there's nothing if those
numbers were off the wall fantastic we
would have heard about it um I don't see
them as being bad I just see them as
maybe waiting til they have better
numbers you know again a lot of people
regardless of how destiny one was
received towards the end and how it
ended and how that game panned out there
was a lot of people to fall off that
game and just just off the strength of
how the bad taste in their mouth of the
first one a lot of people were not going
into destiny to on a positive note or
even purchasing it so word of mouth a
month out after the game is out and
people enjoying it in people saying that
things that people wanted address in the
first one have been addressed you're
gonna see more residual or purchases of
the game so I just say hold the head a
little bit we'll see more concrete
numbers in a while I've seen more people
pick that game up after day one that
I've seen people pick it up day one it's
one of those like wise things it's it's
one of those but much all my friends are
playing it I guess I have to actually
buy it I don't watch they act like they
don't want to act like they be enforced
- that's funny that's good well you are
basically forced into it because I have
a lot of people that jump into my party
and if I'm talking to a whole bunch of
people about destiny and you got a
couple of guys that shout out to green
Mason that'll jump into my party and
we're all talking destinies like hey
what up King what's going on how's this
of the game we like yeah we don't really
care about that oh if you're not talking
destiny talk um the doors that way bro
and then you have somebody that's real
disrespectful in the party or yell out
not the party mommy I mean so if you
hear that as your friends is playing
this and you want to be inclusive we all
want to belong to something so if you
see your whole friends playing destiny
you look over you like well you know I'm
playing as mad and nobody's playing with
me yeah exactly
get it together join the Destiny clan
will one you throw it but definitely
what he says we he means him he's help
me one people through stuff so don't
don't don't sit there and listen to his
stuff he's he's not antisocial he's very
social he's just Manti new friends no
new friends he's about that part but
listen we we want gamers to get their
gaming skill up and we want them to be
part of our raids because there's
nothing better than looking at your
friends list and having confidence and
clicking on somebody and saying yo I
need help here
absolutely so yeah definitely man me I
think the Lord's enough to have to
probably solve you want to say something
or you get it oh no I'm good on it I'm
Jimmy as a noob as a new book
fell off the first one I would say look
it really has his hooks in me so anybody
who's kind of on the fence about it give
it a shot if you like shooters shooting
mechanics this and Call of Duty are the
top of the line so I would say play it
definitely up so shut up to to chat
right now they were in there a lot a
couple of questions they want to ask the
laws before we close out you know so we
wanted to actually PS down you know say
he's one of them he had a question in
reference to the Xbox one X rumors about
overheating now I I heard rumors of this
I don't anything fat food that was the
first thing and the second thing I know
shout out the victor in the chat he's
been lit he wanted a question he asked
us about you know if we were in charge
of Xbox you know like how would we
basically run it like right now like
what what would be the things that we
would kind of put in place so those are
the two questions I'm gonna let this go
around the roundtable start with a lot
at it what do you feel about this
supposed rumor about Xbox one I haven't
heard anything about it but on of the
Lords have and then the second thing I
flew in charge of Xbox what will we do
right now get things poppin I mean did
you guys really expect it not to be
overheating at launch well I guess
because it is no small thing we're
talking about I mean you know damn
straight but it's it depends what
widespread is it what what's what's the
the amount of units that's doing it I
mean how do people actually really know
this who's saying this where the rumors
coming from these are things I need to
know before I make videos about facts we
need some links on that PS now
definitely yes I'm down we need you on
that but what about our to Victor lore
Victor's question and reference to um if
you were in charge of Xbox right now for
the fall for holidays what would you do
get this situation going first thing I
do is make it look like a black VCR oh
wait nevermind just like you know like
there's people in the community it's
like oh it could look like whatever it
wants to look like as long as it
July
the aesthetics of a machine is just as
important as what it does and you know
maybe not for the American audience as
much but there are certain countries
that look like yo [ __ ] looks like trash
I'm not buying it and it's it's very
White's right you know Lord Lord King
David's about the premium experience if
it doesn't look premium he ain't about
buying it he's gonna tell you the truth
for us the truth when it comes down to
it's like the way a console looks is
just as important as what it does you
know I think the names of law is is
lower than what it looks like you could
have something that looks
high-technology
it has a trash name and it does better
than something that that you know is an
average name that you know has a good
cool
catchy name that looks like trash and no
one's gonna pick it up like the original
Xbox one okay you maintain this look and
all that good stuff
let's give it over the Lord Kings what
option what about what about you if you
one thing about these supposing rumors
about you in charge of Xbox you know
what would you do right now look what
would you do different all right um let
me let me really adjust the the whole
overheating stuff all right um whoever
planted this story the fake news story
and it is done to build steam going into
or launch to try to hurt a launch of a
system listen they're sold out Papa
nobody cares about anything overheating
you know what they're doing they're
looking over to the side and say that's
your box is over nobody cares about you
over there send it back in a new one um
it happened stuff happens
you boot up stuff it don't work have you
ever turned your phone on and open conky
and you had to go back to our t-mobile
to look at that fixed look at their fix
shut up nobody kiss all right well um
next as far as how would I run Microsoft
um I can say I could take Peter Morris
ow
I love
I loved when he came out and he showed
their tattoo on his arm
I felt like yes the pulse right there
he's taking control he's working with
the wallet and this is how it goes I
honestly believe penny Moore had a carb
lunch this checkbook was wide open he
was able to do anything that he wanted
to do I don't think Phil operates in
that same space and you got to ask me
how is my bankbook if my bank book is
Peter Morris bank book I'm appealing
would style it I'm gonna go in I'm going
to buy everything I'm going to shut out
the competition I will put my foot on
Sony's neck so hard that honestly you'll
be ashamed the only system my mind like
my commercials we'll take it back to
Sega does with Nintendo I will go back
to that dinner that will break them down
I will fold them up and I will get him
up out of here
now if you're gonna tell me my my my my
checkbook looks like Phil's checkbook
well then I gotta move in stealth mode
I gotta move like how film moves and
Phil is strategically placing his ducks
in different spots and if you're
watching how it comes together it's a
masterclass on how to move on a budget
it was one of those people that he puts
the whole puzzle together but the puzzle
that connects it all to make it look
like a picture yes yeah and that's a
good point about you know the argument I
know we had just pull a while back you
know the whole Peter more thing and
that's a good point in Phil's defense I
mean he's operating in a different
financial space at Xboxes right now and
you we have to give him that credit in
the sense that it's not like the Steve
Ballmer days when the checkbook was
loose right no all this going on or even
with the red wing like Steve Ballmer
back the truck up and said look yeah
what do you need you know he was on arm
IGN south along McCaffrey and he talked
about that story he said it was a water
shot Mormon they called it a Tylenol
moment because at that time back then
town no had a situation where like they
were poisoning all these people this is
before like you had the safety lid over
the
and it was a moment with if they didn't
address this Dayton under and they knew
they were gonna take a short term L
without having to spend so um you know
they say look how much do you need
we gotta fix this issue these systems
are red ringing and it's a different
time and fulfill one of the main reasons
I think the overall brand was more hot
it was doing better at the time so
Microsoft was more willing to give that
kind of initiative investment and then
you know at the end of the day I don't
know what so Spencer does I don't know
that man like that you know for from my
perspective it shows he's doing a good
job but you know it's like when they did
that big interview with all those people
you know uh
shoudl or Seamus he definitely lists it
I know Peter Morris said one of the
biggest things that you need in this
business is someone up in the higher way
above you that is pulling your name and
is going to help you push agendas and
maybe no don't have that maybe he
doesn't have that person above to help
him it's like you know with the game
scenario people say you know what
developers a lot of the times three or
four people keep a game alive
because they want they push for that
game if no one pushes for the game
chances are it's getting canceled yeah
yeah I mean in terms of the cooling
situation with Xbox one X yeah at launch
you're gonna have issues with anything
but I get in like the the vapor cooling
that they big food it in the excess a
typical fan that all you know apart from
it not for having an issue mechanically
that all should ensure that that system
doesn't overheat on any sort of normal
basis so it's it's a whatever it's
probably a quirk of manufacturing or
whatever but I don't think considering
what they went through with the 316 only
units that have a difunctional cooling
you know yeah that's that's probably
what it is cuz be honest when they went
through the 360 how how they over
engineered the Xbox one the original
Xbox one they're not gonna risk having
that be an issue I don't really see that
being a widespread issue at all and and
and
terms of how old I would run xbox I have
to agree with Lord King on that I'm a
Peter Moorhead and um I'm of the mind
that you have to you have to attack your
competition in the way they attack you
you can't take a high road and and I
completely understand the situation
would feel where the budget isn't the
same his mentalities approach is not the
same so I wouldn't expect him to handle
the situations in the same way but I
think Sony has not conceded anything to
them have not taken a woman on the neck
and I mean - off yeah and Microsoft has
to attack in etch in that form to show
that their knee and fight you taken the
high road on something just makes you
look kind of weak so me let me let me
ask you this quick more stuff to that
point what do you what do you feel about
people who say well maybe they've
already writing's on the wall maybe
feels looking long term as far as this
generation you know saying if that were
the case then what I would have done to
kick-start the next generation is you
sell the Xbox one XL $400 are you
Kickstarter you like here we go this is
where it starts because again it's it's
you have to show that you're in the
fight that you're not taking a different
path and again maybe in a long term that
path could be fantastic again with all
the services and stuff that they're
offering in the long term the ecosystem
is gonna be stronger for it
but in the head-to-head when somebody's
looking at Dan who's winning who's
winning this competition Sony is
constantly doing things to show up Xbox
and Xbox is not willing to do that in
return and it's and it and it matters it
matters so yeah I would back up the
truck man I mean I would back up the
truck and I would I would have all those
third-party deals in place I don't I
don't hate on Sony for it I mean some of
the stuff is messed up you know waiting
a year for destiny stuff and whatnot but
you know what hey to the victor you know
that you think baby they have the mind
share they had the mind share and they
could finagle that sort of deal hey yeah
I'll finish this up with them yeah he's
great the shots a check and I like the
poll this week yes please
help us evolve anyways go man go
anchorman is in my a playing destiny
right now real quick before we do the
poll finish this thing off um this is a
great question to be a sent down shout
out the victor I'll sneak those Lords
great question great dialog real quick
monsters pretty much on the same page
the Lord as far as the cooling thing you
know I haven't heard anything it out and
one would think with the vapor cooling
system that's implemented in the Xbox
when ex that that was purposely designed
for that purpose so let's wait and see
until things become you know we get more
definitive results on that as far as
running xbox I think loss of Lord King
you know you guys you're not like
knocked out apart the whole thing is
it's I think she'll fear said yeah he
said that there was a Xboxes I'll be
feeding boys the guy that's like taking
it personal
it feels missus the galaxy all right
first place is that kind of guys like
we're all winning yeah and I see the
point you know sometimes you do you
don't have to be disrespectful but you
can be aggressive you can compete you
know I'm saying shout out the Lord Chief
Tommy yes you can do both at the same
time it's just sometimes when he built
that way yes sometimes reception comes
off as reality it may not be true maybe
he may be doing these things behind the
scenes but you know that's one thing
that has to happen you know the
reestablishment of exclusives and first
party games that have come from XOR
Studios needs to happen and um like
Laura said I felt yeah I do agree I felt
the 400 was a missed opportunity to be
extremely aggressive
however I will give Phil this I think
he's strategic
I think he's thinking long-term I think
he does have a plan in place I do think
people are really sleeping on 2018 I
think 2018 is really gonna be a positive
year for them I think a lot of things
are gonna line up for them software wise
and I think they got some surprises at
Electronic to the point of 2018 like
Sony did 25 yes that's the vibe I'm
feeling you know I feel that they've
kind of see the 2017 and you're just
gonna live off the Scorpio name but I
will say that for the most part Sony I'm
not taking nothing from Sony but I think
we can agree to a law that
you know Sony was you know selling off
the height for the most part for the
beginning of generation until this year
this year they came out with guns and
they said this is why you buy our stuff
and I think Microsoft wants to turn that
around next year so that's what we got
and like I said great show guys it was
poppin so I'm gonna actually give the
first thing I want to say is you know
our whole perspective on how we we've
run Microsoft or anything like that to
my knowledge no one on this panel is as
you know has a major or any kind of
doctorate or anything in marketing so I
Oh anyone that's so happens to watch
just I don't feel I don't want anyone to
feel like we stepping on people's toes
it's just perspective of something on on
generally no situation that I don't
think either of us would ever have like
we don't answer your big billion-dollar
corporations
I don't really know what it would take
to ask someone for money like I have
never had a position where I can ask
someone for a couple hundred million
dollars and go to giant meetings or I
have to talk to these individuals about
if that money did not succeed we can't
Kanye the situation an [ __ ] for that
title but what is your focus to say but
my poll question is a lot of people you
know with the rise of JRPGs and the
white things are going since 2016 and
2017
do you believe Microsoft is essential in
order for them to you know for the most
part you're great
I wouldn't say regain the throne but you
know make the playing field equal do you
think they needed be more aggressive
towards Japanese orientated games I like
this I like this is good this is good I
know this is actually something cows
talked about as well it's out to the
tech podcast group there's a good one I
will post this up and like I said the
Lord's feel free they're always throwing
these stuff good food for thought I love
the engagement Ellen
one myself and I always keep forgetting
why do I not ask the other lords to
throw this in the mix like what's wrong
such as look a little does a little too
much it needs to take some stuff off his
plate and plus you guys have great ideas
so love my Lords
so we're going in this thing up real
soon so armed shout to the chat
absolutely lit and armed let's get these
outros poppin Lord addict
where can the fine people find you
what's going on with the other shows you
dealing with what and what main kids me
are about to do some reviews or a review
gigantic and Destiny's Thursday or
Friday one of those two days I do want
to say I'm gonna start streaming a
little bit more I've been wanting to
make videos but then I see I need to do
the rain I end up not making videos but
I will be next week I'll be home back to
normal schedule you know
for the most part daily content get more
Lord King in your streams absolutely
hilarious no man my life stream got
flagged for unappropriate catch a lot of
content that my jokes is crazy the jokes
is crazy but then on the dirty side
don't watch it with the kids
[Music]
people find that profile ever we wrap
together
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'll check on those settings a sovereign
being on PSN and Xbox Live and Lord stop
IOP on Twitter the XS game I've been
telling you guys and now one of you guys
they got a Playstation I know you in
here so you better freaking add me
alright its Xbox 360 level oh one is a
monkey picture alright like I said it's
not what you wanna hear but what you
need thanks to the chat everybody that
came through
much appreciated we got some cool things
lined up in the next two weeks I can't
spill the beans completely but so
hopefully some some cool guests and some
some cool things popping cost opposed
all that stuff we'll have the results on
again all our audio guys please go to
the inner circle look for the inner
circle network on iTunes Google Play you
know YouTube I know you guys are loyal
to the IOP brand and we love that you
still stop by there to listen to the to
the audio and stuff like that but please
follow the latest us want the latest
audio the latest YouTube stuff that's
live and direct please follow the inner
circle Network shout out to the tick
Fame for always showing us love and yeah
we're about to get out of here so
everybody get to their football have a
good one have a good Sunday on the
Lord's Day there we are
please